on a de nombreuses questions des
téléspectateurs ce soir et on a
également pu piquer là donc on va le
canard et quels sont les spectateurs et
tous qui bonsoir poker salut cyril ça va
et le jeudi c'est quoi ces poussées qui
sait tous qu'ils dépensent y aurait bien
vous rencontrez un joueur pro qui a on
verra bien à l'aide voix
ok vous avez quel âge alors petit en
discrets sans fin non mais si mes bêtes
parce que je les fais pas je vais vous
le dire j'ai 33 ans comme la triste je
veux finir comme ça vous allez nous
mourrons d'isabelle morini la silhouette
qu'on voit c'est vous la absolument pas
non non non ce serait trop simple
ah oui ça brouille les pistes
complètement on il vous dit on est bon
et là c'est la nasa alors vous qui vous
avez tout observer oui ce qui s'est
passé vous avez toujours la caméra dans
le dans les loges maquillage n'a bien
sûr non partout même à y en a encore
bien des planqués partout la huawei a
encore compliqué d'autre part très bien
l'espagne jamais démontré cette semaine
je voudrais à nouveau très dégagée j'ai
besoin de jean-michel l'envoyeur voleurs
à elle est revenue c'est lui mimi ça va
oui pour commencer je voudrais demander
aux chroniqueurs dont jean-michel qu'est
ce qu'il pense du rallongement de tpm
peu plus de bonheur qui va parler du
tiff
d'ailleurs on est on est vous allez voir
on est là je crois qu'une destruction
fondation riders sur un nom alors entre
18 heures
d'ailleurs ce sera dans le parisien je
crois dimanche alors weepu qui pour quoi
vous pensez qu'allah qui sont pas
contents bah oui possiblement on va dire
que jean-michel compte combien de temps
il reste avant d'aller en boîte de nuit
on a des images bien allons-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est de cette façon
mon quatrième top il fera exactement
demain je n'y avais la chair pour bébé
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est une honte effectivement mais
je vous rassure cyril il y en a qui sont
ravis que l'émission se plus longue par
exemple lisa elle est très contente et
c'est pile poil le temps qu'il lui
fallait pour pour se révéler non c'est
vrai qu'à se réveiller maintenant
beaucoup avant la fin exactement c'est
pile à l'heure qu'il lui fallait vous
avez des marques oui bien sûr je les
adore et bientôt très beau cadeau pour
le slip p'tits loups
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
je me trompe d'un sexy mois
c'est chaud
[Musique]
m
c'est très très fort et vous qui nous
dit tout et vous pouvez nous poser les
questions à une première question
après avoir de dire surtout qu'il ya
plein de choses vous le dit à l'ats des
trucs de fou il paraît que vous mêmes
des trucs sur moi pour qui a bien sûr
c'est d'ailleurs quoi vous en premier
d'ailleurs
ah oui allez je profite la caméra
première question ont été refaites voir
une question pour les téléspectateurs
étaient les spectateurs à l'isi avant on
l'entend pas merci merci on va au lit
sur les lèvres
j'aurais voulu savoir qu'il est le
chroniqueur qui a fait la meilleure
rentrée merci ben la meilleure rentrée
alors je vous dis je trouve que j'ai
fait tous une très très bonne rentrée
franchement sincèrement vous êtes
vraiment à fond ou sur cette année pour
moi la meilleure rentrée
[Applaudissements]
nous dire dans l'instant ce qui s'est
passé parce que mathieu est un rendez
vous très important canal clause par
clause de rendez vous alors vous allez
nous en parler dans un instant mathieu
donc c'est pour ça qu'il est un petit
peu en retard je me dis c'est pas grave
c'est canal+ c'est la maison mère de lui
donc il a le droit
du coup ça arrive toutes les missions
qua non merci
les shérifs sur lui pour moi qui a fait
la meilleure rentrée je vous le dis
sincèrement ça fait plaisir c'est une
femme
pour moi la meilleure entrée poteau si
isabelle et sincère dont parce que c'est
elle est là depuis très très longtemps
elle a su se renouveler
elle est encore dans les analyses se
trouve que cette année elle a fait à
chaque fois elle fait mouche même si on
la vanne tout ça mine de rien elle nie
toujours des trucs très pertinent et
elle est toujours aussi drôle elle à de
nouvelles danses rétro et des dents pour
moi ma chérie je te fais un gros bisou
je trouve que tu fais là millions
vous êtes d'accord avec moi
304 rentrée exceptionnelle isabelle
mathieu delormeau on appliquer là vous
avez vous dire pourquoi vous avez rendez
vous chez canal+ dans un instant
j'espère que vous avez des bonne
nouvelle à nous annoncer un ajustement
plus c'est l'actionnaire de ses mythes
donc voilà c'est la meute c'est le même
groupe ou qu'ici nous invoquons et
d'autres questions pour pièces que vous
l'avez d'autres choses ce que vous avez
vu d'autres choses cette semaine
oui sur vous bien sûr je faisais dans la
numérologie quoi on est sur deux volets
oui si vous avez même développer votre
propre théorème oui la numérologie moi
on va découvrir tout ça le terrain'' de
baba c'est parti
[Musique]
la numérologie je prends ton nom de
famille chez full tilt poker 1200
j'enlève le 0 0 je garde le 12e et je le
place la rue le 12 le 2 l aile plus de
et galen le rpr la balade je suis là
jobin est là et bat un connard section
un peu numérologie la soirée
[Musique]
ou qui sait rien et c'est vrai un ben
oui j'ai vu ça s'est fait en plus je
bosse on a on a alors vous avez vous me
direz que j'avais vu que j'arrive à l'un
des numéros le lien j'ai un don vient
donc je le referais je le fais mon
direct un jour j'arrive pas à le faire
d'habitude mais je vais essayer de le
faire en direct
vraiment ça me demande énormément
d'énergie
c'est vraiment énormément de résultats
étant même résultat et excusez moi c'est
pas écolo 3 soit bio il est persuadé
qu'elle connaît pas l'âge des personnes
est comme ça t'en sors sa femme
l'appelle à tantie rythme fête annuelle
plus sur notre avenir chéri et la ccit
magique le mec états pour qu'ils avant
qu'on ait une autre question des
téléspectateurs est-ce que tu as
d'autres choses bien sûr sur les réseaux
beaucoup de personnes se demandent ce
que vous faites pendant la pub
maintenant que vous avez pu le droit de
pas de téléphoner de regarder vos textos
et bien maintenant vos chroniqueurs sont
obligés de penser par eux-mêmes
alors je ne sais pas si c'est une bonne
nouvelle quand on voit la conversation
cas kelly avec ses camarades sur la
viande de grison
ah oui quelque chose c'est très
intéressant on la préfère regarder
regardez
[Musique]
des tirs étaient bien des regrets on
n'est pas une révolution mais des
grillons sécher de deux voire plusieurs
[Musique]
m
à croquer bouquet oui je vous entends
alors qu'est ce que c'est alors c'est
quoi la viande de grison c'est quoi
c'est un petit animal 50 justement selon
vous c'est un petit animal ou un compte
en suisse et quand chez vous à votre
attention en suisse quant à lui à côte
un canton suisse qui s'appelle les
grisons un petit animal d'accord doit
devenir un petit animal c'est non il est
bien on va regarder les réponses à un
expert vous pas dessus de leurs baux à
caen moitié sénile à niort la viande des
grisons la vidéo de sa lésion de la
viande de boeuf concours de guérison
pour ceux que ça intéresse il a tendance
à la bise hongrie
[Applaudissements]
ce point mérité pas que j'étais sur moi
j'avais déjà fait un montage non non non
et un désir était sur google bah oui on
s'y attendait défendre les vols aller on
essaie qu'il était sur nrj 12 elle était
pas sur la chaîne parlementaire
mais c'est bon un parlementaire et c'est
vrai parce que ça veut dire mais
l'ancien a pas les vaches il a fait
mouche il n'a pas fait mieux
[Applaudissements]
j'ai quitté le bureau de maxime saada le
numéro deux du groupe canal pour venir
prendre des insultes et sur le dire ce
qui s'est passé à coray puce dans un
instant et parce qu'il avait rendez-vous
à canal+ mesurer avec les grands patrons
sony wii pour soi rien de cassé la boîte
à blagnac assez justement vous avez une
belle délicatesse on le sait vous prenez
soin de vos affaires ah oui la patience
n'est pas votre truc parce que cette
boîte était déjà cassée ouais j'ai les
vidéos on au regard des autres
délicatesses merde
[Musique]
si j'arrivais pas à louer et nos clés
dessus c'était fait exprès mais
j'arrivais plus match et j'ai plus la
cleda j'ai vu j'ai vu mais heureusement
vous avez des doutes bricoleur c'est
vrai oui
vous réparez tout sur ce que vous faites
ouais et regarder
[Musique]
hoon
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes plusieurs dans votre tête vous
baiser mais seul il est autosuffisant
jamais eu la dent les analystes parlent
tout seul et doit il regarde s'appelle
les gens ont dû me trouve je suis beau
c'est pas beau vous êtes vous êtes vous
en faites mais mais c'est vrai qu'est-ce
qu'il ya mathieu n'a rien à dire je vous
regarde ce qu'on a vu maman que vous
parliez de tête plusieurs têtes
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes plusieurs
de vos têtes d'ailleurs y'a pas éclaté
depuis marche on regarde la vidéo qui
suit là c'est sur moi ça oui c'est vous
encore souvenais pas ce que vous faites
avec votre tête
on n'avait pas voir de moi je vous adore
bah vous êtes mon sujet préféré mathieu
si c'est bien elle minaude c'est la
ligne mélodique à phalsbourg pour mieux
se mettre avec elle mais oui ah oui
alors l on a quoi pour qui c'est sur moi
là dabio succès sur vous on lance la
vidéo à anosy
[Musique]
c'est ma nouvelle te tais alors nous
loue lui ai envoyé des fleurs etc
donc ils ont essayé de retrouver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
capé 1 matthieu delormeau donc dans le
groupe canal+ avec lazy région de cartes
à puce ou qu'ils escomptaient une autre
question est ce qu'on est une questions
des téléspectateurs puisque vous me
posez des questions également le jeudi
on sait que vous aimez s'est remise dans
une autre question pour qui lit à halle
c'est parti une question pour kelly
c'est parti bonjour t plb salut baba
cédric de marseille j'avais une question
pour kelly vidéo midi juste pour savoir
si à tout hasard elle était célibataire
curiosité voilà bien je vous embrasse
très fort gros bisous à tous et
j'espérais très vite le même de max à
cédric de marseille que j'embrasse temps
avec une photo de sa meute derrière
[Rires]
alors est ce que vous êtes célibataire
ou pas oui célibataire célibataire
clairement célibataire clairement
savaient ce qui était beau temps était
célibataire revient c'est un bon genre
seul genre nada que dalle non nadal
raphaël c'est vrai aussi ouais c'est ouf
c'est dans la ba écoute et badr est vous
vous montez pas jamais les tons et son
chant c'est quoi ah oui c'est ça son
genre sait rien encore c'est la
naissance de l'amour
bonjour c'est des grisons et c'est vrai
là il a raison c'est quoi votre genre eh
oui pour dire bonjour c'est l'amour non
les frontières c'est le coup de foudre
au bout physiquement sans fil de foudre
c'est à wiesen importés qui a peut être
pensé qu'à ça va faire plaisir
ça va faire plaisir à vos axes laver son
nom mais qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est quoi
c'est un coup de foudre on s'y voit la
cdc les dents
non mais des dons des fidèles ça marche
voilà vous avez des dents vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
deux questions une autre petite question
à une autre petite qui suivront enfin
rassurez vous qui bat j question pour
métier à terme à l'expression
poursuivent ils lorsque matthieu
delormeau va voir son problème cette
année on l'espère tous je vous envoie ce
monsieur je pouvais répondre à pour moi
cette question c'est notre tout le temps
être dans l'ue mourir aussi - faut se
poser à l'est et allez on y va aller au
delà les chéris bouclier est ce que tu
as d'autres choses bien sûr alors avec
bas jamais on sait que c'est l'amour fou
entre vous deux
j'adore cette baston alors c'est sympa
mais il faut faire attention dommages
collatéraux à savoir les invités quand
en plus la pauvre fabienne carat à
l'abri la pauvre c'est quoi cette
histoire dont on regarde la vidéo
rappelle plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était quand même vous êtes des galas
c'est comme d'habitude 1
chaque fois on me côté jane frétille
invités fait le ménage cnda c1 sur
l'émission l'invité fait le ménage à la
limite vous faites ça bon très bien il
ya une petite erreur d'aiguillage ça
tombe sur l'invité à priori normalement
l'animateur s'excuse et monsieur j'avais
failli d'avenir et une amie fabiana
habassaise camani elle m'a dit si je
vois plus belle la vie hein mais c'est
vrai j'ai presque envie de le revoir
parce que non mais ce qui est magnifique
c'est à tête de fabienne qui est un
amour famille car elle fait partie de la
bande en fait la personne ne pourrait
pas permis avec un invité qu'on connaît
pas très bien
enfin si mais au regard des voix la voix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ego même cet ego c'est comme
d'habitude 1
à chaque fois vous coûter cher entre
éthique elle habitait pêle mêle à celle
d'un gars c'est la seule émission là il
y à poux qui qui est avec nous matthieu
delormeau nous a rejoints il avait un
gros rendez-vous dans le groupe canal
matthieu delormeau il va nous dire ce
qu'il en est ressorti
puisque vous êtes venu en retard à
l'émission expressément pour ça et nous
assez juste que maxime saada me
présentait ses excuses et que tout est
rentré dans l'ordre
d'accord donc maxime saada c'est le
abbas et je les ai acceptées présidente
c'est le président du directoire alors
juste en dessous de vous numéro deux de
leurs leaders
c'est un ami maxime il vous a présenté
ses excuses il va dire il va nous dire
ce qu'il avait dit qu'il m'attend retard
qui vous avait parlé de moi et un
instant vous lisez fois on me concernant
c'est ce que confie que vous étiez un
enfant quoi vous avez joué vous aimez
jouer vous aimez en perte et le monde
ah oui alors à pousser pour qu'ils
voient tous et nous dévoile tout le
jeudi
vous le savez dans tpm paix en direct
époux qui vous avez des images de moi
oui bien sûr j'ai des images de vous
j'ai que ça à presque donc tu plaisantes
j'en ai sur vous aussi les chroniqueurs
on peut on peut boire de quoi vous
parlez
bien sûr on voit tout de suite à
regarder
ce qui rend pas la caméra activement
prieuré nique et à tétouan avec badge et
de retrouver des amis chez lui très bien
que 102
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
d'ailleurs ces boues qui fait la
connerie après vous venez dire bien
serré en tout craché
alors oui c'était moi oui moi je vous
faisais c'était valable que ce jour là
ouais bah c'est la gueule de la personne
que ce jour là d'accord d'accord
maintenant que myers immature tout cas
vous ne voulez pas mais ne faisant rien
alors on a des questions et on a
également bien sûr d'autres vidéos
qu'est-ce qu'on ad'autres pukki sur les
chroniqueurs patients passés au plus
croustillants 1 j'ai beaucoup aimé votre
tête la semaine dernière quand je vous
ai annoncé que j'allais me des caméras
dans vologe ah oui oui alors ben on
regarde vos réactions époux qui a eu la
bonne idée
depuis la reprise de tpb de mettre une
caméra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc alors et époux qui vous c'est vrai
qu'ils sont extrêmement stressé pourquoi
vous êtes stressé comme ça qu'on a mis
des caméras leurs cloches benhaim
surtout une année aura sera soumis non
mais parce que c'est une partie de notre
intimité non non non non mais vous dites
d été du tout dit désolé tu dis la
vérité on dit des horreurs bennett dave
il dit j'ai une peau cap sur vous ou
nous dit la vérité ou bien je la dévoile
sa lancée vous avez dit notamment en
loge qu'elle est persuadée que son
l'émission d'eric naulleau qui
commencera ce soir de cochon elle fera
moins d'audience que lors de la télé est
[Applaudissements]
une ordure médaille vous l'avez dit le
premier qui voit la rolls et mais je
pars voilà donc pourquoi vous étiez
aussi on angoisse aussi comme ça vous
avez un truc sur moi non mais dites le
pour moi non non non pas parce qu'on se
raconte nos là il faut si nos vies
privées ou qu'est-ce qu'on a des choses
mapuku bien sûr qu'on a des choses
justement benjamin benjamin bientôt sur
vous bon apparemment vous avez capté
j'avais mis une caméra avec vos petits
yeux c'est bizarre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a capté que vous avez une caméra way
a pas vraiment d'ailleurs il a voulu
m'aider à piéger une de ses camarades
alors c'est très gentil mais on va
laisser les professionnels faire leur
travail
on peut regarder un benjamin on y va ses
missions et un petit point
[Applaudissements]
alors qu' on supporte pas bouger très
vite il a dénoncé jean
obama et moi j'ai parlé des potes herman
n'ont devancé le pire
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a voulu faire une caméra cachée à
kelly s'était tue de catastrophe ou
est-ce qu'on vienne questions des
téléspectateurs avant qu'on prenne avec
cookie qu'on sache ce qui s'est passé il
y en a plus et malgré deux langues
oui bien sûr on a une question twitter
pour agathe tient une question twitter
pour agathe allez-y on y va question
twitter pour agathe
allez-y tient agathe si tu devais
choisir une seule émission ce serait tpm
pub btp a passé sur la balance ton post
tout à l'heure aussi étaient pipés que
vous devez choisir entre les deux ce
serait quoi touche pas à mon poste
touche pas à mon poste a ouais ouais
pourquoi bah ça me déchire et le car
mais bon si on rigole on rigole beaucoup
plus ici quoi donc l'avouer geste ça
peut-être dans votre élément quoi
rigoler j'aime bien faire des dark revan
a répondu en tout cas elle a répondu moi
s'il devait choisir un chroniqueur ce
serait vous mathieu à ses vrais vont
l'enlever
oui oui oui pour le virer
[Rires]
j'hésitais entre toi et isabelle la
meilleure entrée je te le dis parce que
je sais moi ce qui est mignon c'est que
à la ktm caméra tu es tu fais la petite
blague derrière mais quand c'est par
texto au téléphone à la latte et tout
mignon
charest concernant bien moins chérèque
pour qui oui alors il ya beaucoup de
gens qui me demandent est ce que les
chroniqueurs son pareil dans la vraie
vie qu'à l'antenne
enfin enfin beaucoup de gens en fait
c'est juste ma mère qui me demande ça
alors je réponds oui sans hésitation
enfin en tout cas pour isa et et mathieu
les disputes sont vraiment si forte en
plateau que dans la vraie vie je vais le
découvrir mais bien heureuse de
souligner les aspects trop d'orgueil of
immunology kovalainen
je défie la langue de 21 ans aujourd'hui
je parlais je me connectais ça va tout
seul mais je sais qu'ils sont mes choix
d'études et je suis un carton jaune
bêcher venir prendre mon argent et tu me
fiche c'est bien mais ça n'est pas
possible merci avec d'autres c'est
cynthia qui s'occupe des chroniqueurs
cas vous êtes très prometteur beaucoup
des blancs non mais elles étaient près
de montcuq près de lamballe grandes
époques calmes à +13 vous dire pourquoi
dans un instant mais pour qui est ce qu
on a d'autres choses marchaient bien sûr
après l'émission normalement c'est
l'étape du démaquillage pour certains
pas pour d'autres
mais y en a qui sont très rapides et qui
expédie sa très très vite et il y en a
d'autres pour qui c'est une vraie séance
d'estimé de soi
regardez
ap
à
[Musique]
c'est à poser aux chevaux tandis que je
tente dans le miroir et l'a donc pour
préparer l'émission a fait une belle
rentrée elle veut être quatre minutes
pour se démaquiller avec tout ce qu'on a
sur la gueule c'est pas énorme mais on
n'est pas des petits copains de valence
tout poste ici mais voilà je te le dis à
rodez redescendre a créé une belle robe
elle fait une belle rentrée c'est son
retour devrait vous êtes revenu dans les
branchements pas très et vous je suis
très content vous fire moi je suis très
heureux je croque a fait une très bonne
rentrée à gan franchement elle est
souriante ali d'arc allez allez vous
êtes plus drôle qu'avant
ouais c'est vrai je trouve que vous êtes
mais liorel habillé différemment cette
meilleur esprit qu avant non mais c'est
vrai vraiment c'est quoi comment ça se
fait
bassel après c'est la guérison on
rappelle non pas inutile de le rappeler
mais bon la question est un peu la leur
on rappelle l'été voilà voilà vous êtes
période difficile et ça va pas faire les
difficiles et que prétendre à mieux donc
ça vous avez fait prendre conscience des
priorités ouais ou de ski et ski
essentielle pourquoi alors y en a une
autre qui a d'autres priorités et qui
sait qu'il y kanye
elle arrive tôt avant l'émission pour
choper les meilleurs maquilleurs avant
agathe pas spécialement agathe oui où
tout le monde quoi vous arrivez à tout
pour avoir les meilleurs maquilleurs à
la vérité c'est que j'arrive tôt pour
esquiver les bouchons mais c'est moins
intéressant donc bien bas en tout cas
merci trébosc on a d'autres choses bien
sûr il ya aussi les pique-assiettes
celle qui est en race ramé alors en ra
sera totale dans les loges avec un vin
vous le découvrirez nasa
[Musique]
c'est
montrent les chiffres moins mauvais
choix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes sûrs d'angoissé beynat ça va
moi j'aime ça je suis toujours heureuse
et je suis heureuse ici mme rose 13e
ressort pas de quoi vraiment passe très
bien pour prix est ce qu'on a d'autres
alors je t'avais justement valérie
puisqu'on est sur vous vous savez votre
émission c'est un petit peu raccourci on
est d'accord
oui oui on l'a on le retient de
circoncision est là dans une amputation
là allez on recale afin record
d'audience il ya meilleur
vous m'avez vrai axim aux adorables oui
c'est vrai mais ce que vous connaissez
la blague que fait cyril quand vous
venez à peine de francs par quoi
j'imagine quoi pour qui c'est quoi la
bague découvrir ça quand elle commencé
l'émission oui à peine commencées les
missions que vous faites une blague
dessus elle est bonne je verrouille pas
regardé
on atteint vite yamanaka des beaux jours
[Rires]
et avec l'afrique a dit aux gens c'est
là que la famille mission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
doré comme tous les deux avec ça je la
fais tous les soirs salage voulu recréer
il m'avait même dit attention j'ai
cligner des yeux
l'émission est finie j'adore s'il est
très généreuse et à tous les jours dans
ma loge et hier à la fin je vous redis à
la fin un record d'audience
on s'était réfugié hier quoi céder
connaissent déjà la guerre de cent ans
des missions et sujet hier hyper
intéressant rien il réagit leverdez
d'ailleurs qui a fait une émission l'
exception c'est vrai vous avez arrive
voilà bravo a été très bon dans sa
jeunesse mais j'entends comme ça en font
oui oui alors je vais faire un truc qui
me ressemble pas du tout alors il faudra
bien en profiter en fait j'ai fait le
trou dans le top 3 pardon des
chroniqueurs les plus gentils les plus
mignons ceux qui m'ont touché parce que
j'ai quand même un choeur terreiros
poitrine
il ya eu 1 à 10 pas 10 parce que il faut
savoir mine de rien vous êtes une
famille segway
vous aimez tous ici mais sans rigoler
vous aimez mènera bien sûr vous raconter
toutes vos histoires de sade heures
juste avant qu'on voit ça il ya une
question d'un fan 12 jeux sur vous ils
disent ils demandent à ce qui est des
chroniqueurs qui se voit en dehors de
l'émission qui se voit le plus quelques
chroniqueurs se voyait le plus en dehors
de l'émission je pense que c'est jean
michal et mathieu non oui j'ai raté mes
pulsions michel eymann vanony morts tous
les soirs de la même semaine ensemble
avec son chien les sushis dans la télé
d'une fois par semaine environ
est ce qui permet à leurs mathieu vous
comment terminer que mathieu oui c'est à
dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une amitié durable car il savait
qu'on est parti trois jours ensemble à
aix-en-provence ya la fin de l'été
devrait dans un petit hôtel ont été très
millions pour la piscine il est jeune
fille qui veut nous voir et qu'ils a dit
je suis très content j'étais sûr que
vous étiez ensemble voilà moi je pars
bientôt en week-end avec isabelle
j'espère qu'il va m'arriver la non mais
c'est vrai il s'appelle on part bientôt
week-end ensemble pour les spectateurs
sachiez on est en train d'organiser ça
sera dans avant pendant le mois qui
arrive à partir tous les deux évoqué la
gérance de l annuler les gens grosses
salades ont regardé le top 3 des moments
mignon quand même puis regarde
ils gagnent ma télé ce conte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
très belle
[Musique]
mais voilà que c'était pour ebay les
magnifiques la télé france au violet qui
est tellement heureux de gagner ma télé
ça m'a touché mais en quoi c'est vrai
mais bon c'est pas voter sinon c'est pas
vraiment votre télé merci merci j'ai une
télécommande border j'ai pas tout groupe
non mais sérieux et solide rodez sur
biarritz a arrêté dans mais aujourd'hui
c'est une télé comme ça donc je vais
vous dire j'étais chez d'artistes tels
moyens n'avaient j'ai pas dit oui mais
j'avais décidé de cette taille chez moi
n'ont ni d'être beaucoup plus grands il
ya des gigues en appel à l'aide de tout
désir et de tous deux des gigantesques
télé vous croyez quoi bon la gare par
doan et gigantesque telle icône avec moi
j'en ai compté huit cols après la dérive
quoi c'est vrai ya quand même piège
c'est moi moi j'ai compté huit élèves
c'était votre ipad
les téléspectateurs sauvez-moi nouveau
coup du mal
franchement j'ai une télé comme ça dans
ma chambre je ne rigole pas alors pour
qui le numéro 2 les numéroter c'est
jean-michel le groupe hayot on le sait
mais vous êtes aussi capable d'être un
bon camarade et c'est pas valérie qui va
me contredire les sauvetages de son
brushing
elle vous le dois tellement c'est beau
c'est 500 gardes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez
[Musique]
c'est lui
d'ailleurs
le numéro 2 des minots me badat poutou
[Musique]
jean michel aulas et jean louis tout
craché mais c'est le genre mis tout
craché il cachait chez jean vigué s'est
passé parce qu'en fait c'était une
séquence osé la mairie qu'on leur
demandait de faire
d'horribles aux résidents des jets
d'oeufs en neige il fallait monter et
enlever le truc et normalement ça ne
coule pas et bagheri benhaim ballon la
cuisine c'est pas son fort et elle
n'avait pas réussi et jean-michel oui et
je lui ai les galères et donc je l'aimé
beaucoup c'est quoi
bah je propose d'échanger parce que moi
je savais que j'avais réussi j'ai
consulté son fils que je lui demande et
où il me dit très gentiment dont un joli
brushing du gain en échange est tous
vraiment c'est beau c'est beau et fort
est le numéro 1 des mignons c'est qu'ils
n'iront dénigrement la numéro une
elle est mignonne si la plus mignonne de
la semaine c'est notre petit qui lit tu
peux être tous fini
non elle est très délicat ni sa méthode
voilà qu'elle est trop mignonne quand
elle apprend qu ophélie winter va
peut-être mal
c'était touchant ah oui bon on regarde
mon sarkophilie net serait sans domicile
fixe voilà qui est on pourra parler dans
un leçon je vous dis bien entendu mais
aussi la célébrité on en parle dans un
instant
dont légitimité jusqu'à la sortie de son
troisième album lille iii qui sait qu'on
a le premier exemplaire est dans le
sigle sache sera disque d'argent
muzito vous invitera par exemple
plusieurs films et séries 7 ans balles
comme à cliver novelli ampleur mignard
et elle refoule heures encore tori vous
êtes avait les larmes aux yeux en voilà
encore elle a rejoint maré a b c est
incroyable
alors ma mére minnelli pour ophélie
winter il paraît que vous pouvez
l'accueillir chez chez vous mais oui
avec grand plaisir d'accueillir aussi de
la chance aux qualifs c'est vrai oui
mais à l'habitation elle chante toujours
pour ceux qui sont là c'est une
constante dans sa vie
oui mathieu qu'est ce qui se passe me
disais que vous avez vraiment des bonnes
vannes fait vibrer c'est ce que j'aime
dire à l'instant me fait plaisir
vous êtes arrivé un petit peu tard on
n'avait pas pu alors aujourd'hui cette
année vous avez une raison matthieu
delormeau est arrivé en retard ce soir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous aviez
rendez vous on m'a dit jean riant madila
rendez vous chez canal+ qu'est-ce qui se
passe oui mais après je parle on peut
refaire trois tonnes cette histoire
parce que je peux mettre le groupe mal
on va dire comment je pourrais dire est
simplement canal+ pas manqué de respect
maxime saada les grands dirigeants
jusqu'aux monsieur bolloré mais je leur
ai fait savoir
donc j'ai convoqué enfin mons est
convoqué on sait trouver un moment pour
se voir c'était à cette heure là pendant
l'émission et je m'en excuse auprès des
téléspectateurs et des fans et donc du
coup j'ai su zahlé dans leurs bureaux
est ce qu'il s'est passé mathieu et moi
c'est quelque chose qui était mon sens
voilà mon depuis je dirais 19 jours
exactement 19 jours qu ils vous ont fait
du mal oui dix neuf joueurs et
dirigeants de canal+
oui et ça non souhaitez vous voir pour
s'excuser absolument c'est nous qui
voulons rappeler en vrai c'est quoi
absolument ce qu'ils souhaitaient
s'excuser suite à ce qui s'est passé par
la suite mais ce que je dis est vrai
donc voilà je n'avais pas prendre
d'avocat et tout ça comme vous dites
c'est l'arrivée de nouvelles d'avocats
alors la première c'est donc ça la wii
mais vous savez tous ici donc je le dis
depuis 19 jours et 7 heures mon mon ma
box canal+ ne fonctionnait plus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quel écran rigolade
des techniciens se sont présentés donc
je rassure tout le monde c'était la
carte mère a demandé des réparations
avec mon avocat et notamment mon père
mais maxime saada donc du groupe m'a
présenté ses excuses et donc je les
accepte et on en est resté là agata
vague atteint puisque agatha c'est la
productrice pour qui est ce qu on a
d'autres choses marchent agatha au cas
où il ya une enquête qui serait faite au
oui alors oui je sais que vous traitez
bien vos coéquipiers ouais bah justement
par exemple agata on va en parler
agatha la productrice et julie gens ce
n'est pas parce qu'il ya à la agatha la
productrice et le jeudi mais julie la
conductrice des autres jours et oui je
les aime bien mais oui on a des images
vous est vachement lait coûte de vos
équipes
ah c'est pas la même façon à vian c'est
notre pacte ses membres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est joli raid où la pandémie elles
vont me parler mais comme si de rien
n'était alors tu vois donc là tu vois
cette personne-là abc vous serez gaulle
eric naulleau qui vient d'on n'est pas
couché qui a fait plein d'émissions il
voit l'animateur morin - calais la
presse qui parle de ses intérêts c'est
tout on a un accent j'espère mais non
bien sûr que non vous avez encore veut
garder votre âme d'enfant normes
enfin plus l'attention d'un enfant c'est
à dire 10 secondes avec agata justement
la productrice et c'est parti
regarde c'est pas grave
[Musique]
la nuit porte conseil
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
agata et julie de me supporter et vous m
mercier je les aime fort à les deux vous
avez vu s est d abord panda on a on a
des seins dernière chose pour qui bien
sûr au delà des blagues nulles pour
terminer c'est bien ça l'est déjà cnil
des blagues nulles wee bb des lieux jeux
de mots pourris quoi mais alors c'est
spécial jambes il a exactement partie
les regards des japonais effectivement
away un sushi bar est pas du tout
[Rires]
j'étais sur les chemins de compostelle
quand vous m'avez appelé les grosses
têtes et nous avait appelés c'était la
révélation pour le suivi sur la béquille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va dix30 région patate après ma
dernière ce losc woippy qui vient
d'arriver c'est quoi ça concerne kelly
je crois oui mais quand ferme kelly b si
orléans toulouse est clair qu'il y
laisse trop faire alors on se pose pas
mal de questions sur ce que tu fais
pendant pendant les émissions notamment
avec ta chaise ah oui parce que j'ai
remarqué entre les c'est pendant la pub
kenny elles baissent c'est ce pourquoi
on regarde vous avez la réponse
[Musique]
je ne sais pas du tout pourquoi pourquoi
fait-elle ça bah oui la réponse tout de
suite hein c'est quoi pourquoi on c'est
bon
car
[Musique]
c'est lors c'est mieux parce que tout
cela c'est comme ça donc c'est énorme
bravo franchement bravo pour moi